we're asked to draw the line of
reflection that will map quadrilateral s
o RT s o R T on to the other
quadrilateral below so this is the other
quadrilateral right over here so we want
to reflect s o R T so it maps on to this
other quadrilateral and we wanted to
font we want to draw or define the the
line of reflection using this tool right
over here and so see if I just kind of
eyeball it it looks like it looks like
something something like that is
starting to get close but not quite
and what the way I could tackle this I
could look at corresponding points I
could say look Point s right over here
in in the image after the reflection the
corresponding point is that right over
there and so the line of reflection
should contain a point that is halfway
between these two points and so what's
the point that's halfway between them
well let's see where I have it right now
is it halfway if I put it there
that actually looks halfway between this
point and the corresponding point in the
image notice to get from here to there
I took one to the left I take one step
to the left three steps up to go from
here to here I take one step to left
three steps up so these are definitely
the same distance away from this point
and this point are both the same
distance away from this this line or at
this point that's on this line so now
let's see where this point could go and
I could do something similar I could try
to find let's see I need to find a
different point let's see maybe maybe a
point that's halfway between this point
and T and the corresponding point in the
image which is that over there and let's
see I could probably put it that
actually looks pretty good because this
is one step to the left three steps up
and then to get from here to there one
step to the left and three steps up so
this looks pretty good this looks like I
have to I have drawn the line of
reflection this point that I'm
highlighting right now in orange is
halfway between T and the corresponding
point in the image this point right over
here
is halfway between between s and the
corresponding point in the image you
need to just have two points to define a
line this looks like my line of
reflection let's see whether I got it
right and I did